[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em felony
[Music]
oh man
you found out the witnesses that are
going to be used against him
and he's freaking the [__] out oh my god
of course he is why wouldn't he freak
out over the witnesses one of them is
Mark Meadows I'm sure
how long that's the question I've got
how long before Donald Trump
releases on true social or starts to
talk [__] about the witnesses that he
just found out about in Jack Smith's
Discovery huh
what do you think how long it's gonna
take you think it'll be over the weekend
I don't know I don't know I mean I guess
we'll find out the other thing that
we'll find out is when he does start to
try to witness tamper if judge Cannon or
Reinhardt
will stop him
because you know oh he's [__] pissed
he's pissed he's and you know what he
wants to do he wants he wants the the
House Republicans to save him
they can't even hardly [__] pretend
to save gas stoves
and Define
Adam's ship for six million bucks did
you see this yesterday
oh my God what a [__] [__] show Our
House of Representatives is
I thought we were gonna have to cover
them wall-to-wall but they can't do [__]
the only reason why these [__]
buffoons are concentrating on gas stoves
and Adam's shift is because they have no
policies none
they have no agenda to even bring to the
floor
oh by the way
news just doesn't quit Lauren bobert
Marjorie Taylor green want to get in a
cage match wait or is that Elon Musk
and Mark Zuckerberg hey can you can you
get me the uh the facts on the cage
matches Let's uh let's do that
apparently Marjorie Taylor green caught
Lauren bobert a little [__]
or was it Lauren bogert called Marjorie
Taylor green a little [__] or does it
even really matter
oh my god listen a lot of people like oh
my God this is such a disgrace they're
disgracing our country what what did you
expect when you vote in and these are
your [__] representatives of Congress
do you think they're gonna [__] do
you think do you think for a second that
they're gonna represent you in a decent
way get the [__] out of here
these are piles of garbage that's all
you're gonna get is [__] trash from
these piles of garbage speaking of piles
of garbage and news
and House Representatives George Santos
which ah baby we're right on the dial
that news should be dropping right now
of who is the special secret donor who
bailed George Santos out of jail that's
right folks today is a [__] waterfall
of news
or like an ocean full of news
all the way down to the Bottom of the
Sea Under the Sea
they still haven't found they still
haven't found the boneheads that decided
it was a good idea to get into a beer
can
and sink themselves with some cinder
blocks I think all the way down to the
Titanic surprise surprise did you know
this listen to this good Lord listen
hell listen
apparently this is not the first time
that this [__] shitty ass submarine
has made the mission down to the Titanic
I guess I don't know oh it's [__]
crazy wild [__] they still haven't found
it though oh boohoo
that'll teach you to tie your own bungee
cord without practice that's what it'll
teach you
like Texas Paul said the other day we
really need we really need these
billionaires to get some training
they're just not trained very well why
would you do this anyways
well let's see what other what other
crazy [__] shits in the news today
I guess um what what was the what's the
thing about the cage match I read that
Elon and and uh Mark Zuckerberg want to
get in the cage match listen Elon man if
if people are talking about how Mark
Zuckerberg is gonna kick your ass
you're not the tough guy okay you're not
the tough guy you think you are if
everyone's talking about how Mark
Zuckerberg is gonna kick your ass in a
cage match really come on man what is
this
what the [__] is this
so that's the news oh uh Ronda santis uh
tries to throw a punch at Donald Trump
that's news we're gonna watch that video
for sure for sure I'm gonna mock Ron
DeSantis for trying to land a bunch
trying to land a bunch
on Donald Trump do we have some news
here hang on a second
oh [__] it looks like U.S Coast Guard
says debris field discovered in the
search area of ocean gate Titan
submersible
everyone's really picky about these
words they're like it's not a submarine
doesn't have seats in it yeah it doesn't
have seats in it because
they couldn't buy the seats on Amazon
right they couldn't get the right seats
at Camping World so they just went
without seats otherwise they'd had seats
in that [__]
Am I Wrong tell me I'm wrong I'm not
wrong if they if they could find seats
that would fit in there from Camping
World or Amazon they totally would have
had seats in there 100 percent
um so I don't know if this debris is
from the Ocean Gate submersible
but um if it is well
you paid 250 000 to die at the bottom of
the sea so I don't know I don't know
what the hell you know a lot of people
are like oh this is so sad it's such a
you know listen if anything this is a
[__] lesson this is a [__] lesson
to people who have more money than they
got [__] brain cells okay
look all the people that have been in
this [__] thing that have went down
to the Titanic because apparently this
is not the first mission mission or tour
foreign
a theme park or something
all the [__] people who pay 250 000
to go down to the Titanic in this beer
can listen
this is the thing
they could have all pulled their money
together they're probably Rich enough
that they actually could have made
themselves a craft
that they all could have got in and went
down and [__] did this [__]
but no no they settled for some dummy
to to to Jerry rig as Gabe Sanchez put
it together Jerry rigged some [__]
some [__] propane tank because that's
kind of what it looks like a propane
tank
did Tyson cinder blocks to it with and
and give a an Xbox game controller to
sync it to the bottom of the ocean come
on man and you're gonna feel sorry for
these [__] get the [__] out of
here
I don't feel sorry for him no I'm not
going to and I'm not I'm not gonna stand
here and cry and pout
as they paid 250 thousand dollars
to see their demise
like I'm gonna cry for Trump because
Witnesses are turning against him no why
what this is your own doing this you did
this like I said this is the same [__]
this uh someone's asking who had the
news it's uh MSNBC is uh what we got
here I'll show you the clip here in a
bit
I'll show you the clip here in a bit uh
we have Gabe Sanchez waiting uh also for
the uh George Santos news to see if
we're gonna have um some news on who who
maybe maybe hey you know what I didn't
even think about this until just now
maybe one of these [__] on the
Ocean Gate
is George Santos's uh bail money right
and they're like [__] that I can't go
back to the surface maybe they sabotage
the ship or the submersible the
submarine maybe they maybe they
sabotaged it that way
they didn't have to hear the news today
that they were the one [__] I don't know
hell I don't know who do you think it is
you think it's harder than Hitler you
think it's uh oh the the singer Guy what
do you think or do you think it's more
of like a a Russian style name
that we're gonna hear what do you think
what's your guess I don't have any
really good guesses I don't know it's
someone with a lot of money who has
interest of keeping a lying sack of [__]
in Congress and that in that weird
yesterday uh the last two weeks
these Republicans have been obsessed I
mean obsessed and they've been turning
on each other even Thomas Massey they've
been turning on Thomas massony calling
him like a rhino and [__] he's oh he's a
liberal now you're part of the deep
State Thomas mancy is part of the deep
State get the [__] out of here listen
we're part of the deep State and we
don't want him okay you got it uh deep
state does not want Thomas Massey you
can [__] keep him all right keep that
[__] but here's the thing
they spent all this time all this effort
they failed to censure Adam shipped at
first last night they were successful at
making him the number one candidate for
the U.S Senate seat in California is
what they were successful at I mean they
censored him and they're going to give
him an Ethics investigation not really
it's not going to matter because he's
going to be the U.S senator in
California the the person who really
suffers the most in this whole debacle
is Katie Porter who she wanted to uh run
against Adam Schiff in the in the
primary now for the U.S Senate seat
they're in
they're in California so the loser
really of Adam's ship being censored
because he's he's going to propel
himself to the United States Senate I
don't know if you've seen his speech
we're going to watch all of it or part
of it today holy [__] this guy's like
thank you thank you for voting to
censure me this is fantastic listen if I
had an enemy if I had an enemy it would
be you treasonous [__] I mean it's it's
beautiful and they're only they're only
going to uh send him to the United
States Senate which I don't know if you
know this but the house Ethics Committee
has no jurisdiction uh listen if you get
a Twitter law degree like Tom Fenton uh
in the judicial watch over there you
might want to listen up you have no
jurisdiction over the United States
Senate or United States Senator so good
luck you dumb [__] ah you guys
did a wonderful job making Adam Schiff
the [__] United States senator from
California again the person who suffers
the most here is Katie Porter because
she had a good shot but [__] uh the way
that they made
Adam Schiff the Enemy Number One and the
way that he uh [__] did such a
marvelous job of burning them down
yesterday after they did that and
pissing on their ashes oh man it's
[__] great he's like this is the best
line he's like oh you wanna now this is
my take on it right this is like if Tony
Michaels was on the floor speaking for
random [__] but he's like oh you want to
find me six million dollars well you
better raise it to 160 million
[__] because I ain't going
nowhere I ain't going nowhere and you
can do it once you can do it twice you
can do a thousand times [__] I'm here
to stay and and he's going to be
I don't understand why the Republicans
think it's a good optic to cinch your
atom shift for defending democracy and
defending our country against a bunch of
treasonous bastards
and then the very next day we're gonna
find out who George Santos their little
[__] whatever he is in the house
we're gonna find out who who posted his
bail I mean within a matter of minutes
I'm sure it's already dropped somewhere
now if we got to if we got the news it's
gonna come soon so we're gonna know that
but you you think they're gonna get rid
of George huh Georgie Porgy hell no
they're not gonna ever get rid of
Georgie Porgie they need him for those
important votes to save gas stoves and
to get rid of Adam Schiff like they need
him to vote on that [__] that's the
dumbest [__] I've ever heard in my life
and the reason why they're focusing on
the stupid gas stove and Adam's shift is
because they have no platform they have
no policies
nothing I mean other than an impeaching
Biden and the two little two little
trashy little [__] not not my words
there they call themselves little
[__] not me
I I was archery Taylor green and caught
Lauren bobert a little [__] or was it
Lauren voter to call margin green a
little [__] I don't know it seems
almost equal
um oh the filing not yet released but
MSNBC is apparently saying that the
sources say aunt and um father gave him
the bail
so it's family members they gave that's
what they're saying so far we'll see and
the filing has not been publicly
released yet we're going to get that
we're going to get that soon
um someone's saying Marjorie Taylor
green called Lauren bobert a little
[__] you can see how I'm confused by
that though right I mean come on
couldn't you see it that that's a
two-way street on the little [__] on
little [__] Avenue right I'm not I'm
just saying I could see Marjorie Taylor
green calling Lauren bobert a little
[__] is it just a [__] or is it little
[__] maybe maybe Lauren bobert called
Marjorie Taylor green you big [__] and
Margie Tater green called Lauren bobert
you little [__] I don't know I I listen
I what I think we should do is we should
get a committee together in the house to
investigate this and find out I mean
this is important stuff we got to know
folks I mean we [__] we're trying to
find out how big hunter Biden's [__] is
we need to figure out who and what and
when Lauren bobert and Marjorie Taylor
green called who a [__] and win and why
and how big of a [__] our little of a
[__] for that matter these are
important things we got to know this is
literally [__] that they would probably
have a Committee hearing on what don't
you think
this is how [__] ridiculous these
people are
this is how ridiculous they are but look
it's not surprising because after the
worst interview of all time all time
listen even the R Kelly interview do you
remember that it [__] destroyed him
there were still people out there like I
don't know if I believe and then the
interview happened like yeah that
[__] did it oh my God that
[__] did it this week Donald
Trump gave the worst interview of all
time
excuse the expression trumping the R
Kelly interview
and [__] still supporting him
I told you this would happen this is
what happens when you have a cult okay
you're not gonna get rid of the cult and
I'm gonna I'm gonna show you a video of
Ron DeSantis oh [__] this guy
not understanding how Cults work he just
he they don't listen until you [__]
idiots figure out how Cults work you're
not gonna figure out why Donald Trump is
going to be the nominee you're not clear
on it yet okay I see it clearly I've
seen it clearly for a long time that
Donald Trump there's no way these
[__] are gonna push him out and
if this interview that Brett Baer did
with him didn't destroy him which it
hasn't I I see this as [__] a lot I will
run to Santa's went up two points in the
poll what are you [__] kidding me
listen if Ronda santis isn't swapping
this [__] yet
he's got let me let me give you some
facts the organization that Trump ran
for decades was charged and convicted of
17 felony fraud counts his CFO went to
Rikers [__] now
he was charged in New York
for 34 felony business fraud charges
okay indicted now in the [__]
Southern Florida after he was President
this [__] happened after he was
President not before not during after
he was charged with 37 felonies
arraigned last week
37 are you counting do you want me to
account for you do you know I mean I
know magnomics doesn't compute very well
but that's 37 additional Federal
felonies
that broke the Espionage Act
are you [__] following me yet he gave
the worst interview on TV of all time
and political history no no other
[__] interview not even an R Kelly
interview really isn't political but it
doesn't even hold a [__] candle
to that interview they it was such a
[__] show that Fox News had to release
it in two parts
that's how much that's how much garbage
and trash there was in that interview
they're like look we can't do this in 15
minutes we got to show the whole [__]
thing
the world's gonna [__] love this [__]
and they're still supporting him dummies
they're still supporting him is Rhonda
Santa spending money like it's going out
of style yeah sure
yeah they're they're throwing money man
oh my God and it just speaks to how much
Republicans hate hate Grandpa poopy
pants they [__] hate Papa felony they
hate that's my new nickname for him by
the way we got Cheeto dust q and honor
we had Grandpa poopy pants and now Papa
felony I I narrowed it down to those
pawpaw felony I kind of like that one
that's a new one but it's a pretty good
one so but Paw Paw felony they're trying
to throw all the money they can at this
[__] it's not working
it's not working here's how you know
it's not working because they'll say
[__] like the the Santa's [__] idiots
will say [__] like well the fantas has
come up three points in this poll here
and Trump went down for some stupid [__]
like that like look if DeSantis isn't
swapping this dumb [__] already you you
do not understand how elections work you
don't understand how primaries work
okay he would be swamping him if he was
taking the lead he's not it's not it's
and it there's no Slow Burn with
DeSantis this guy's such a [__]
weirdo the more you the more you learn
about him the worse you [__] the the
worse he is and the more you hate that
[__]
that's just how it is
with DeSantis that's his world that he
lives in
and today this morning Papa felony is
freaking the [__] out begging Congress
begging congress the people who couldn't
save gas stoves and who could barely
censure Adam Schiff
he's begging them to save him that's how
desperate he is and my guess
my guess is he saw the witness list and
he saw one name on that list that he
does not want on that list and that is
Mark Meadows because Mark Meadows knows
every [__] thing Grandpa did
to the to the T he's probably got it
written down on his notebook somewhere
I'm not [__] you I bet there's
[__] notes that he's got oh and the
other thing too
that I bet Donald Trump discovered in
Jack Smith's Discovery evidence is that
people around him were wearing wires
I'm not you know
here's the thing would you [__] go in
a room with Donald Trump or be on the
phone with Donald Trump without
recording every [__] second of
that
would you want to be exposed to criminal
liability just because I mean even the
staff man if I was a staff member at
Mar-A-Lago you goddamn wide I'd wire up
even if I was just delivering the guy's
Diet Coke or his Big Macs you [__]
ain't right I'd be wired up ready to
record
you can't tell with this sumbitch
someone's saying Secret Service you damn
right there's Secret Service agents on
the witness list that are gonna have to
testify too he's [__] Capital f-u-c-k
[__] [__] [__] is what he is and
he knows it
and now that the discovery is clear see
here's the thing
and I don't know if a lot of people are
aware of this it's Tom Fenton it's
definitely not aware of this
how does this who get takes legal advice
from this [__] what the [__] are
you serious is it the same person who
picks out his shirts Jesus Christ
anyways
listen here's what happens when you have
a federal case like this
what happens is the prosecutor right or
law enforcement doj FBI ATF whoever it
is they collect up evidence right and
then the prosecutor is like well is
there more evidence and they collect up
more evidence
they use their subpoena power to get
people to testify in front of a grand
jury based on that evidence
right and what they're doing is they're
laying out a certain set of facts
okay
and those facts are called evidence in
this case you're going to hear the word
Discovery a lot that's the basis of the
case that's the facts that the defense
trumps lawyers who won't be paid and
he'll continue to change them to delay
this process that's what he's going to
do by the way he's going to delay his
he's going to delay delay delay by
firing the attorney and then hiring a
new one then that attorney has to have
time to get caught up and then you'll
fire that one then it'll hire a new one
and the judge Cannon will keep giving
him more [__] time because he's got
to get a new attorney because this
attorney's [__] anyways the point is
this
that Discovery is the basis of fact in
which they're going to argue their cases
in front of a jury
now when the facts
have no defense
it's pretty bad and I would imagine that
after his attorneys whoever the [__]
these people are at this point
looked at this discovery because
apparently I have to have adult
supervision right they have to have
adult supervision to look at this [__]
you can't make this [__] [__] up man
this this is a weird time we live in
what a time to be alive you're never
going to see politics like this again
probably uh in our lifetime so enjoy it
[__] enjoy it here's the thing
I almost bet that these attorneys went
back to Donald Trump after they looked
at this discovery and said oh baby
you are going to prison for a long time
my friend you need to cut a deal and you
need to cut a deal now and I would
imagine he told them to go get [__]
and that's the first ones he's gonna
fire
whoosh I'm glad you're here today it's a
huge news day it's Thursday June 22nd
um it looks like the it looks like the
um the the George Santos news is
dropping looks like the two people that
put up the half million dollar bond is
his father and his aunt
that's that's the big reveal that we
have I mean you know George Santos
should definitely resign I don't want
him to I don't want him to what would
they do without old Georgie Porgy what
would they do without him they couldn't
they couldn't save gas stoves for crying
out loud Jesus Christ make sure you
while you're here on the YouTube channel
we have a big audience watching today
make sure you subscribe right here on
the Tony Michaels podcast don't forget
to hit it it's free 99 you get a five
finger discount on this show here on
YouTube that's right it's free to watch
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
on YouTube and Twitter don't forget to
follow us on Twitter Tony Michaels pod
you can also watch over on Facebook at
the Tony Michaels make sure to follow us
over there you can also watch on the up
wires channel the upr.com go follow
their YouTube channel or just type in
the up wire
on YouTube you know there's a little
[__] search bar at the top of YouTube
you just type in the up wire boom it'll
bring it up and I want to thank all the
people who follow us over on Twitch huge
following happening on Twitch and a huge
chat over I know everyone likes the the
up wire chat it's Lively everyone loves
the YouTube chat here on our channel the
Tony Michaels a lot of people like that
twitch chat too and some people like the
commenting on Facebook and we get them
all right here now I'll tell you on the
Twitter broadcast you can't I mean you
can comment I just can't see it and the
reason why it's because Elon sucks at
this right Elon sucks is bad at Twitter
as this Ocean Gate CEO
um is bad at putting billionaires in a
in a beer can attaching some cinder
blocks and singing it down to the bottom
of the ocean
now we got a special guest for you today
Major Richard Ojeda we're going to talk
about classified documents he has a he
had a top a secret clearance I talked to
him the other day on the phone he's
going to give us what his take is on
some of these documents and his grandpa
poopy pants Papa felony is freaking out
this morning over this discovery I would
imagine that because this morning I want
to tell you this discovery that they
have so far is the non-classified stuff
that's right he's freaking out over the
[__] that's the non-classified stuff we
haven't even gotten to the discovery of
the classified stuff yet so don't go
anywhere we're going to talk to Richard
Ojeda major Richard Ojeda right after
this don't go anywhere we'll be right
back right after this
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
trying to remember all the things you've
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with these
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show everyone wants
the boycott binder to be [__] on you
especially the mongoloidites they're
like yeah where can we get one
I'm trying to find a beer I can drink
queer beer oh my God yeah you wish the
boy God binder was real don't you or the
pardon blanket Everyone likes the pardon
blanket
now you know what is real you know what
is real we have a website that's got the
[__] Pride merch and you should go
check it out go to store.d Tony
michaels.com this is a request from the
chat from Miss loveseek in our chat and
the chat lit up on this say yes we want
a pride design to the [__] em logo Gabe
Sanchez delivered you guys you guys love
the tank tops and the stickers and the
fanny packs we got t-shirts too but the
fanny packs the stickers and the tank
tops are going like crazy so if you want
your pride [__] merch just go to
store.dtonymichaels.com that's store dot
the Tony michaels.com and we don't have
the boycott binder or the pardon blanket
on there yet maybe one of these days
maybe one of these days what do you
think what do you think major would you
buy a boycott binder would you get you a
boycott binder you know I was sitting
here watching that commercial and I was
thinking that's awesome and then when
it's like I realized it was really just
a parody I was like damn man you wanted
one
yeah right right well it's 29.99 for two
now I'm glad to have you here finally on
the show and we talked the other day
um I I asked the audience who we should
have on to talk about classified
documents and someone who who's had a
clearance I I've never had a a secret
clearance they probably wouldn't give me
one even if I tried I mean that it's
because probably my loud mouth but
that's you know that's how it goes
sometimes but you tell us your history
on your clearance and what it meant and
how you got it how you had to keep it
tell us what it means to have a top
secret clearance when you're in the
military a top secret clearance uh a
secret regardless security clearance is
important when you're in the military
when you are a basically a platoon
leader level to company command level
usually you need to hold at least a
secret clearance and let me tell you
something you know the background checks
that go into getting a clearance it's
severe I mean tell us about that tell us
about that process what do they do is it
is it like just a one-time thing or they
keep doing doing this throughout the
time that you had the clearance well you
know when I received my clearances
people actually went back to my hometown
that I grew up in I mean they spoke so I
had like boots in the ground they were
walking around boots on the ground they
go back they talk to teachers they you
know I mean you literally God damn
you're trying so they're trying to
figure out like if you bullied anybody
on the playground in kindergarten or
something or why would they talk to
these people in your hometown what is it
about that they want to know if this
person can be trusted right you know
what when this kid when he was a kid was
he a you know a little [__] bag you know
that uh that stole [__] and did all
kinds of negative things you know let me
tell you they really need to make sure
that you know the people that they give
these clearance to the clearance to can
be trusted so you know you need a
security you need a secret clearance
from company level you know and down but
once you make the field grade level
which of course that's that's when you
become a major you know you pretty much
need to get a top secret security
clearance let me tell you both
regardless secret or top secret you have
a packet that you have to fill out and
I'm telling you right now it takes you
weeks so you need like three boycott
binders to stick all those papers in is
that what you're saying absolutely
without a doubt I mean you know you have
to and they they ask you all what what
are they looking for are they looking
for like uh money that you owe people
like your mortgage your car loans credit
cards like it goes It goes into that it
goes into what type of debts that you
have because once again do we really
want to give somebody a security
clearance if he is bogged down in debt
where somebody could say hey look I'll
pay off your debt and you've got to give
me some information and all right you
know that you know that sounds like a
story we had the other day where a uh a
Alaskan billionaire
um sent a Supreme Court Justice to
Alaska and then they got like 200 or 2.4
billion dollars like quid pro quo is
that what you're saying like they want
to to make sure that your debt is not
only legitimate but you don't have mired
so much in it that one person can come
convince you to maybe give them some
information or show them or wave it
around maybe in front of them or
something yeah they want they want to
know they want everything and also
questions that they'll they'll ask you
know does this person have any issues
with drugs and alcohol you know I mean
if you've had a past where yeah a guy
used to fist fight all the time in the
bars and get drunk all the time you know
there's a possibility that that could be
held against you and the reason for that
is because it's important we want to
make sure that the people that we give
these clearances to are people that we
can trust and you know just just looking
at you know what what Donald Trump the
boxes that he had and where they were
you know there was if you look at the
the picture of the boxes on the stage
it's like a little oval black box that's
blocking up somebody's face who was just
a random guy in Mar-A-Lago that decided
hey look at those documents let's get a
picture and they took a picture in front
of it and the thing about is is you know
those documents as somebody who has a
who held the top secret security
clearance
had I walked outside of a skiff and
started talking about anything that I
saw inside that skiff I would lose my
clearance and if I said anything that
was actually giving up any secrets
whatsoever my career's gone I'm going to
prison I'm going to be in Leavenworth
and that's an absolute fact well here's
here's what I'll say is we've had
instances of this just in the last week
of people being sentenced I want to
bring in someone else who definitely
couldn't get a classified clearance for
sure our co-host Dave Sanchez come on
man you wouldn't be able to get a
[__] classified Clan yeah no I mean
No No One's Gonna trust me
not with the commercials and the [__]
you do no [__] way no [__] way as
much as you as much as you text George
Santos and you're on his on his call
list no way I'm also I mean yeah I uh
you know I'm trying to check in with
George right now to see did you text him
did you text him yeah but you got to
remember that I'm almost I mean I can
call him later on the show but I'm
almost pretty sure that he got a new
number because
I will tell you that it is absolutely so
sickening for someone like me who back
in 2018 when I ran for congress I
absolutely did everything right I busted
my ass I practically sleeped under
bridges I campaigned like you ain't
never seen and I did everything right I
made myself available to the people and
I got beat
by a person that just said I'll do
whatever Donald Trump wants but when I
look and I see Marge the train wreck
green and Lauren bobert and and George
Santos and I think to myself my God I
cannot believe that these people have
been elevated to the levels that they
are I mean I mean look look I got oh I'm
so happy for her because she was able to
get her her GED but look when you're
talking about legislation on the federal
level I believe that you should hold at
least a master's degree I think that
there should be education levels to this
stuff you know and when you see people
George Santos that guy doesn't even he
doesn't know how to tell the truth oh
and that's an absolute fact he and and
when you've got people like that and
Donald Trump is in this category you
know they think the reason why Donald
Trump is the way that he is and the
reason why lawyers are like they're
dying here is because you can't control
Donald Trump Donald Trump has went 76
years of life without being held
accountable for anything that he's ever
done
no matter what he's he could screw
people over and he would get his lawyers
to threaten to drag them through the
courts until they are bankrupted and
they gave him a pass and Donald Trump
felt that as long as you got that well
that was Victory you wouldn't and then
you must be the guy but I'm going to
tell you you know he was you know Tony
was talking about the the Brett Bear
interview good Lord I mean you know this
tells you could you I don't even
understand how anybody would want to be
a lawyer for Donald Trump first and
foremost
he's not going to pay you he doesn't pay
well the only one that he did pay in
advance uh turns out that that one
actually was uh was kais in Florida and
that was the only one who was like look
I want three million retainer up front
right now
and that was probably the smartest
person on the batch because everyone
else he's either not going to pay he's
gonna throw onto the bus and be like
they were the ones who did that I mean
look at Christina Bob right she was like
you know she was there on the day then
she was like well they didn't let me do
they didn't let me uh witness the actual
search that was being done I was the
custodian of Records then as like just a
few days passed by we're realizing that
oh or she realized that she might be in
more [__] than she signed up for and
then she kind of left the spotlight went
back to rsbn started hosting all of the
Trump rallies because at any point
you're done Alina hayaba like she
screwed up the Aging Carol case she was
done we used to do we used to do a a
segment where we take what Alina Havas
said on TV and we would like you did
like a family matters 1990s theme song
and it was called shitty legal takes and
all it was is we would play you would
put the theme right in front of what she
said that's it if we didn't edit it we
didn't it's called shitty legal takes
and it was her saying something listen I
don't want to disparage any attorneys
out there but man it is not hard to be a
[__] lawyer man come on this is
ridiculous this is ridiculous when you
got these people I mean even Jim trusty
can't trust Donald Trump and Jim trustee
he's an ambulance Chaser he tried to get
in the game with Donald Trump here to
become a media personality and it [__]
the bet on him it [__] the bed so much
so that he had to drop not just the
documents case but he had a drop out of
the CNN uh defamation lawsuit yeah so
but let's talk about let's talk about
though their trouble this morning
and there and the trouble that Grandpa
or Papa felony as I'm now referring to
him Papa felony
um is losing his mind this morning on
true social and I believe in and people
have surmised that probably it's because
Jack Smith dropped the first uh pile of
Discovery evidence on the defense
um and my guess is is that whatever dumb
attorneys that are willing to to defend
Donald Trump at this point saw this
stuff and went oh dude you're [__]
like this is bad and um and the witness
list with Mark Meadows probably at the
very top is terrifying him so much so
major that they are he is begging
Congress to save him here well Donald
Trump always says that he always
surrounds himself with the best people
but you know I'm going to tell you he
absolutely is [__] bricks right now
because Mark Meadows has the mark
Meadows did exactly what Mark Meadows
was always going to do he was going to
hold out and wait until they desperately
needed to get a few things connected and
that's when he swooped in and said I got
the answers to connect those things and
boom wait don't you think don't you
that's a good theory and the reason why
I like that theory is because don't you
think that might have been the reason
why Mark Meadows intentionally got the
uh the uh the criminal contempt of
congress referral to doj so he could
start that process because we'd never
heard a single peep not a single [__]
peep out of that referral for criminal
contempt and it seems like maybe Mark
Meadows knew that the only way to
possibly and his attorneys the the good
ones that like you pay and that actually
want to defend a [__] and they
got this common sense to defend somebody
but don't you think that maybe that's a
pretty good theory that he's like you
know what we'll initiate this contempt
of congress this criminal contempt of
congress and that'll get me in the door
with doj to try to get me immunity
because he would much rather take a
charge on the contempt of congress thing
or maybe some low-level charge in this
document's case then then to participate
and and pop off felonies just spurge of
crime especially when it comes to
January 6th I think this I think this is
absolutely phenomenal and and you know
and once again you can always tell when
Donald Trump knows that somebody is
ratting on him because immediately
they're low energy they're losers you
know uh you know and I look at these
people I wrote some things down uh yeah
he called Mark Meadows low energy and a
loser and you know that means that he
knows that Mark Meadows is busting him
out because Donald Trump I mean this is
a guy who literally has always been able
to get away with anything and everything
that he wants this is the first time in
the history of Donald Trump that Donald
Trump is actually going to be held
accountable and there's nothing that he
can do to stop it this is on the federal
level and he is absolutely [__] and
you know what I tell you you know I sit
and watch I said I mean last night on my
life you know one a person that had one
document
was sentenced to five years in
Leavenworth and the careers are gone
military careers are gone uh that's you
know I mean when you look at what Donald
Trump had and you know I look at these
pictures and every time I look at these
pictures it makes my it makes my blood
boil you saw the pictures in the
bathroom you know I mean and and Mark
Meadows they're not like Meadows but
Kevin McCarthy says well bathrooms lock
I mean what what a freaking [__] but
then you also got the documents in that
one office space area where right across
from them is a freaking printer you know
and it's like how can this stuff you
know Donald Trump is as guilty as you
can get and I want to see him go down on
everything you know Lindsey Graham made
the threat that we there better not be
no more indictments [__] the January
6th indictment is what I'm looking for
because I believe that Jack Smith when
he launches that it's going to indict a
lot more people than just Donald Trump I
think I think that's when we're going to
see Lindsey Graham and and those
[__] who gave the tours to the
Capitol the day before I believe that I
believe I believe ho you know I've been
on enough shows with attack on Doctor uh
of body language that truly believes
that that pipe bomb Setter absolutely
has a lot of things that that look
exactly like the way Old Marge the train
wreck green walks so well I want to
smoke this out for a second then okay so
the story is a and uh Marjorie Taylor
green called Lauren bobert a little
[__] is that what the word is that the
or just a [__] yeah being a little
[__] being a little [__] well it was
it it was it was a little [__] but I
feel like somewhere in there there was
like copycat was awesome okay because
remember like like a nanana boo-boo
sticker yeah yeah
you got two people you go well this is
because basically uh March the trainer
at Green is saying that Lauren bobert uh
stole her impeachment verbiage and you
know yeah yeah
we have to remember that in 2021 so they
keep trying right they keep trying to
impeach in 2021
Lauren bobert sent an email to all of
her constituents and supporters and
people on her [__] newsletter and was
like we're going to immeech
Joe Biden not impeached wow
it is much worse to get a meech than
impeached everyone knows that yes
yeah I didn't mean to get up on a
tangent out a little [__] tangent there
but here's I want to go back to the mark
Meadows do you know why I think because
you said Donald Trump is [__] brisk
so Papa felony
um is just unloading These Bricks out of
it in his diapers this morning but I
think the reason why
um Mark Meadows is so important in this
case that he's turning on Donald Trump
isn't exactly because of the documents
case right
it's because of the coup attempt where
he's terrified that that Mark Meadows
and the reason why because the documents
thing really isn't tied that we know of
yet
um so far in in what we know publicly
about it isn't exactly tied to January
6th it is at some point and the reason
why is because Merrick Garland gave the
case for January 6 and the documents
case to Jack Smith there's one
investigation so it makes me believe
that some of these documents he stole to
cover up the coup right like that's what
I believe and I think we'll see that but
here's the thing
Mark Meadows is not only at the star
witness in the documents case but Donald
Trump knows that he's he's not only the
star witness in that case he's the star
witness which can indict him
um on God knows what charges seditious
conspiracy maybe even with a big T with
treason
um he's the one Mark Meadows is the one
that was right beside him and that's
what really terrifies Donald Trump and
that's why Donald Trump is begging
begging House Republicans to do
something which they can't do anything
yeah House Republicans have no control
over who gets indicted where and we know
that we know that because the January 6
select committee couldn't indict Steve
Bannon Peter Navarro Mark Meadows
himself for for
um
right they can just refer so the only
thing that one branch can do another is
refer and they can oversight but the
thing is is that this is an ongoing
investigation so the FBI and doj can
basically tell Congress to [__] off when
it comes to their investigation at this
point because it's an open investigation
we all know that we know that's how it
works and I think this is why Donald
Trump Papa felony as you say [__]
these bricks in his diaper this morning
is because he knows Mark Meadows is the
key to the January 6th case uh he knows
a lot about the documents but the
January 6 cases where the fear lies yeah
and the one thing I want to add too is
the fact that like you know I feel like
anyone with
common sense or logic or just an
understanding of who Donald Trump is
right when the transcript got released
right people were like oh no no that
it's AI it's it's it's fake it's gonna
be this it's gonna be that they're
trying to come up with any excuse they
can right they're like oh well in what
context was it said right well you know
he really does own they're all
scrambling to find some explanation that
makes any sliver of sense and we've
we've again we've all known this if
there's one of these things there are
going to be multiple if not many many
more of these recordings
and so yesterday we find out that
prosecutors I don't think they
explicitly said it but in the question
based on the CNN report is that they
indicated there are multiple recordings
there are many more recordings of Donald
Trump saying something that puts him in
a you know either a treasonous or you
know the classified as Espionage or
whatever it might be we don't know what
they say but we do know that there's uh
there are more recordings of him doing
it and you know what I said earlier it
goes to Mark Meadows I said earlier
about wires major I said earlier about
wearing wires why wouldn't you wear a
wire or record conversations let me tell
you let me let me paint a little picture
for you you know in the military you
know when you were a platoon leader you
have a platoon Sergeant that's your
that's your right hand right there when
you were a company Commander you have a
first sergeant when you were a battalion
Commander you have a command sergeant
major it is a marriage you know
everything that you do you bounce off of
each other to make sure it passed the
sniff test no matter what it is well
this is the same thing when you're
talking about Donald Trump and his chief
of staff you know leadership in the
military and even in the civilian world
that's there's things that that are are
done and it's done a specific way the
chief of staff is supposed to be the
person that he bounces everything off of
and that's the thing that's why Donald
Trump is scared shitless because he now
knows that Mark Meadows the guy who
absolutely was right there in the
friggin room for every conversation and
every discussion and every decision that
was made Mark Meadows was privy to it
and that's an absolute fact and that's
why he's scared shitless because like
Tony you said I mean look Mark Meadows
is going to get a sweet deal here uh now
I doubt very seriously that we're ever
going to see him running for office
again it amazes me that Mike Pence
actually has the the backbone to say
he's gonna run Mike Pence yeah but I
mean at the end of the day Donald Trump
absolutely every single coffin can be
nailed Shut by Mark Meadows and I'm
telling you I think that Mark Meadows
he's played this out in his mind and so
he had probably had some people that
told him this is what you need to do and
now that's where he's at
yeah I mean if we remember back to the
Jan six uh uh committee hearings you
know
um
Cassidy Hutchinson like you know her
testimony she revealed a few different
important parts one of which was the
fact that Mark Meadows was just sitting
there casually on the couch texting on
his phone and she was like hey did you
hear about this thing that Rudy Giuliani
just told me about about January 6 and
he's like
yeah whatever didn't even look up didn't
even acknowledge her in the doorway the
fact that he was like yeah whatever you
know it's like the as you said like the
guy clearly was there for every
conversation and that's why a bunch of
Republicans including Don Jr and Don and
Donald Trump tried to discredit Cassidy
Hudson because she was with Mark Meadows
all of the time and Mark Meadows of the
Trump all the time so by proxy you're
gonna find out that Cassidy Hutchin was
privy to certain information and I
wouldn't be surprised if there's other
details that she couldn't talk about
whether for
um you know uh
it was not not top secret but it was
might be sensitive information she
couldn't reveal out to the public during
those hearings but again I wouldn't be
surprised if she also was privy to the
information that uh that Mark Meadows
was and so to your point again it it
really is if you have one you'll have
the other and he was always there at the
hip in the meetings always being
photographed always always always and
again these recordings it sounds like
there's at least one with Mark Meadows
and he was planning to do it with
um or in uh
you're planning to do it for his Memoir
right so he was already he was already
planning yeah but understand that you
know Donald Trump is like a child and
and we know that but here's the thing
when Donald Trump thinks
the moment that he thinks or knows that
somebody is rolled on him he
automatically goes into Attack Mode low
energy the guy's dumb uh gutless pig
[__] like that
before that
what Donald Trump does is Donald Trump
lose tries to woo people you know he had
that special Heroes dinner for Joaquin
nauta that we now know he they did at
Mar-A-Lago and you know that was for
only one he don't give a [__] about
Walton Alta all he cared about was Diet
Coke bring me my diet coke and then and
this freaking guy was apparently really
good at bringing Diet Coke to him so
then he took him to Mar-A-Lago and then
he had that guy moving boxes around
hiding boxes Donald Trump didn't look at
wall team now to like he was a freaking
great guy like he's one of my good
buddies he looked at him like he looked
at everybody you're here to friggin
support and do what the [__] I said
right he's a servant he's a servant to
Donald Trump but now that Donald Trump
is in trouble Donald Trump at the last
minute does this Heroes dinner for his
good old buddy wall teen because he
knows that while Tina's freaking facing
it too and if waltene is is freaking
smart he's Gonna Roll too uh but once
again you know if he's stupid uh which
you've got to be pretty stupid stupid to
to to I think work for Donald Trump and
also to do the things that he did I mean
let me tell you something while team
naota is a retired E8 in the United
States Navy explain to the audience what
an E8 is an E8 in the United States
military it's it it's an enlisted rank
but E9 is as high as you can go so you
know command sergeant major below that
is Master Sergeant in the United States
Army the the Navy calls it something
else but it's I mean he did 23 years so
so wait a second wait a second what
you're saying is this guy had an E8 and
he became the Diet Coke guy well team
yeah yeah and that is not a [__]
isn't that about a [__] it is his last
assignment he got stuck he was a cook in
a culinary arts and his last assignment
was in the white house and apparently
Donald Trump liked the fact that they
said I mean this guy must be a big
Bootlegger hey Mr Trump yeah well he had
to see him at least at least 12 times a
day with this guy's bringing him to Diet
Coke he's got to see him a lot you know
he's like I need another Diet Coke I
need another day that's the master chief
petty that's what it is but uh you know
basically here's this button when you
push it I'll bring you a Coco Donald
Trump enjoyed the ability to go being
dark Coke here comes here comes a
[__] E8 to bring you a soda yeah when
Donald Trump left the White House he
said I want to hire that guy and take
him with him the guy attack on retires
and goes to uh but here's the thing that
guy was he's a retired Navy E8 do you
think he doesn't know about clearances I
mean let me tell you something he's
cooking at the White House he has a
clearance I guarantee you he's had he
now when he retired uh his he didn't get
to keep his clearance but you know I
mean the thing about it is you can't
tell me that he doesn't know about that
well let me let me ask you because this
is important right what you're what
you're talking about uh here because
Donald Trump and waltine are the only
ones on this indictment so far right
they're the only ones so far they seem
to be at this point for the documents
Casey only targets now it seems that the
prosecution
um indicted waltin because he wasn't
cooperating for whatever it's worth I
guess the diet coke position was worth
not ratting out Donald Trump but here's
the thing
when you have a clearance like this and
they sit you down and tell you what the
rules are and like what the punishment
is do they let me ask you do they bring
up the words Espionage Act when they're
teaching me about this tell me about
what they teach you tell me about what
they would have taught while teen
probably more than likely and they
probably told Donald Trump but it went
way over the [__] you know
squirrel or whatever the hell that is on
his head but tell me what they tell you
about the Espionage Act and why it's so
important like when handling even just
even just like how you handle it what
you say what's what's so crucial about
that Espionage Act you when you get your
clearance they bring you in and they
they basically just tell you about you
know the do's and the don'ts but make no
mistake about it you know if you you
learn real fast that when you were in an
area that you are allowed to get
information a skiff make no mistake
about it when you step out of that skiff
if you start freaking talking about
anything that you were speaking about in
that skiff you're done in the military
your career is over you're going to
Leavenworth you know I'm going to tell
you I mean Point Blank if you leave this
if you leave this area if you were
caught with classified documents outside
of a skiff you're going to go to prison
in the military they basically just told
us that it would literally end our
careers and we would go to Leavenworth
and in the military anybody that has
been caught doing those things that's
exactly where they go they go to Fort
Leavenworth there's quite a few people
in Fort Leavenworth that are in there
because of classified documents because
they were doing things that they wasn't
supposed to do and if you get caught
doing that you're done it you are done
your career is over and you're going to
go Leavenworth it's it's it it's it
there's no such thing as mid uh it's all
it's all damning doesn't matter what it
is it's damning there's no such thing as
well if you you get caught with this no
if you take something out of a skiff
what Mars the train wreck green did
should have her removed from her
security clearance because she was in a
skiff and she went on television and
admitted that she listened to what they
were talking about they gave them a
document to look at but they had to keep
the document so she left the skiff took
a pad of paper and started to write down
everything that she remembered that they
spoke about in the skiff and then she
went on back on television and started
talking about it I mean she should be
arrested right now she should be barred
from ever being allowed to go inside of
a skiff whatsoever you know I know that
she's dumb as a damn stump and I know
that the district that she operates in
has to be equally as dumb as a damn
stump to keep you know to to to re-elect
some [__] Rick like that you know to
elect her period but that's where we're
at but I'm going to tell you you know
you you do not you do not mess around
when it comes to government secrets you
do not mess around if you go through the
process and I think that they'd probably
go through an easier process unlike what
we go through in the military because in
the military we get that going about 80
page pad of paper and air is questions
that you got to answer you got to tell
them about your finances you've got to
list every single place that you have
lived your entire life everybody that
you've worked with people that you know
I mean if you worked at McDonald's you
got to tell them where you were what
time you know when you worked there who
you worked with it is very very detailed
because they want to make sure that the
people that get this information are
people that can be trusted and obviously
because a member of Congress you know
they're they get a they get a I don't
know what the hell they get but they get
a security clearance as well but
apparently some of them don't don't you
know uh understand the severity of it
people like Marge the trainer at Green
to the mere thought that George Santos
is allowed to let you know look at
secret documents that's the guy right
there you know Donald Trump is a guy if
you think for one second that Donald
Trump would not sell these documents why
was Donald Trump in possession of our
nuclear capabilities the amounts the
locations uh the same thing for our
allies and there's no why would an ally
ever ever support us again if Donald
Trump was to magically win the 2024
election and become the president I can
guarantee you that'll be four years
where nobody will share [__] with us
because you cannot trust Donald Trump
and you can't trust some of these other
people around him I agree 100 major
thanks for joining us you got to come
back and keep talking as the news keeps
coming out because the next time you
come on here's what I want you to do I
want you to teach us what the government
taught you about declassifying documents
with your mind I want I want I want you
to give us that class because apparently
it's a thing that you can just
declassify documents with your mind so I
want you to show us next time
um how you do that can you do a shame
English blood go ahead and do a
Shameless plug whatever you got tell the
audience what you want to plug okay I go
live every night at 8 30 Eastern
Standard Time on oh Jetta live on
Facebook and on YouTube and I am also
the founder and National spokesman for
the new Pac turn left so check it out
okay is there a website they can go to
for turn left just just you can go to
just just go to Facebook and turn left
on there uh okay good so just search
turn left on Facebook search major
ojetta on Facebook go get them on
YouTube everybody stick around major
thanks for joining us we'll have you
back again I we gotta give the whole
audience a class on how to you know uh
mind Mind Trick the uh the classified
document yeah okay next time next time
you'll show us how the government showed
you how to declassify documents with
your mind everyone stick around thanks
major we'll we'll be right back right
after these messages
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
weight was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we have plenty of Slam gems skull
near run out Natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again here's
Bob
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the live love and blue one
in your absence I discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
here's Tammy
come Buckle [__] em [__] em [__] [__]
em we're back to the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the show oh it's from
waterfall news glad we had major on
give us the skinny on how hard it
actually is yet
it's hot secret clearance
from the United States military and the
government in general oh Gabe Sanchez we
got some news what's the what's the
Santos news apparently his family put up
the 500 yeah so it goes to lose [__] the
bet you were hoping it had like a
Russian name or something man I was like
Harlan Hitler I don't know I'm still
there's still a part of me that's like
oh man is it really them like who gave
them the money to put it out like well
here's the the reason is so okay for
anyone who doesn't know George Santos uh
through several attempts of trying to
appeal the judge saying that you had to
reveal uh who the names were because
typically this type of information is
public it is available and so
yeah political other people like they
all they all filed uh you know a foia
request to say we want to know who is
protecting this guy in the sense of like
they they were because they didn't have
to put up 500 000 it was five hundred
thousand dollars if he broke it they
would be responsible for that so it
turns out
um that it was George Sanchez's father
and his aunt who I'm gonna be honest did
not know they existed I did not know
that a come on man you don't you don't
think George Santos has has relatives
hiding in his pocket I don't know man
there's a part of me that thinks it
could show me the birth certificate and
then I'll believe you I'm I'm starting a
new birther movement and it's gonna be
about this uh Jersey no dos Santos Jr
and Elma Santos Previn those are the two
people and the reasons Dan and his aunt
right is that his dad in the sand and
are they brother and sister are they
brother and sister is that the I'm
assuming so okay but the reason this
doesn't make sense where'd they get the
amp main dollars that's what I want to
know well no again they don't need a
half million dollars wow right they they
put up the potential of a house which is
about 10 right yeah yeah so it's just
50. so where'd they get the 50 Grand
that's the big question so the reason I
find this a little bit and by a little
bit I mean a lot uh suspicious because
it's George Santos yeah yeah it's not
there but keep going well his dad
previously worked as a house painter oh
okay well hey I'll tell you I'll tell
you and Michael in my experience in
construction painters House Painters can
make a lot of money they can make a lot
of money they they can make a lot of
money I mean
all I'm saying is there's people who
paint houses and there's people who
paint fences
if people understand my reference there
uh uh if you don't painting fences is
code name for Mob type stuff oh okay
yeah okay yeah yeah people who yeah or
Hitman anyway
um so you're saying you're saying that
George Santos's dad is a hit man is that
what you're saying I'm not saying he's a
Hitman what I'm saying is the the idea
that this guy put was was potentially
going to put up 500k right and and his
sister aka's Aunt uh 500k it seems like
a lot of money right right
um but we also have to remember
so if you look back Federal elections
data shows that Elma s prevent Alma
Santos prevent his and contributed
several thousand dollars to Santa's
campaign and is listed as working as a
mail handler for the U.S Postal Service
so you have a house painter and you have
a USPS mail handler so someone who's in
the back wow I'll tell you I'll tell you
that that between if he actually was a
house banner and she was a mail carrier
between the two of them those careers
could save up 50 Grand Am I I'm not
saying that I'm not saying they can't
I'm not saying they can't but we also
have to remember I'm not trying to be on
the side of Georgia
what I'm saying what I'm saying what I'm
saying is this is not the news that
everyone wanted is what I know it's not
the news that everyone wanted but it
also honestly the reason why the reason
why we should probably get not give a
[__] about George Santos because George
Santos is gonna probably go to federal
prison he's probably gonna take a plea
deal though he did say he did say and
turns out he was lying again he did say
he would rather go to a pre-trial like
detainment
before giving up this information right
so now the cat's out of the bag and
surprise surprise George Santos is still
out in the public right he does not care
he had his family put up the money but
this is the reason why I think it's a
little bit suspicious is because I'm
sure when you when you submit yourself
as a bond guarantor or a a sureator I
think is the the name
um
you have to show your finances right you
can't just be like Oh I'm gonna put down
it like I'm gonna put down this money
and I'm gonna show you that it's like I
have to show you my financials right
which means that they have to prove that
they probably have some liquidity
available to put a 500K and if not then
they say well you're not someone that we
can trust that's where the bond comes in
that's where the bank I got breaking
news here okay breaking news this is on
the Titanic thing oh yeah yeah yeah well
we don't know for sure yet yes but we
actually have a recording I think from
the um and we're gonna get knocked for
this but we have a recording here from
from the uh from the Titans
world around you right here on the ocean
floor
[Music]
one more are you looking for I'm
oh boy
oh yeah Disney's definitely gonna knock
us for that yeah yeah yeah hey friends
for anyone out there if you're ever if
you are ever in public and uh somebody's
recording you right and you don't want
it to
uh be be played online because you want
a strike to come at it or you want
someone to copyright it start playing
Disney music
oh really on your phone if someone if
someone's recording your own public
because Disney will be all over that
they'll they got a whole [__] room
full of lawyers that the plans Beatles
music uh but especially Disney and the
reason it's I mean as as a as a normal
person
it can be effective but cops also use
this same tactic that's how shitty they
are because they don't want to be filmed
so they pull up their phone and they
start playing music because they know
that when you post it online not that
you couldn't do it without but the audio
obviously makes a big difference when
you're trying to make a case against
someone Joan on Facebook says Tony that
was funny but in bad taste yeah I I know
I know that's why I did it
listen listen if you got a good taste in
your mouth about this story about these
billionaires paying this money to go to
the bottom of the ocean and [__] I don't
know did you see have you seen this the
stepson of the one guy yeah he's out
he's out trying to get with [__]
people on Twitter and [__] like only
fans models and he's like uh please
again baby I want you on my face
through some
vulgar yeah
was it yeah he said the N word and said
some other [__] harder harder oh wow
okay well so let's since since we're on
social media here and that guy well
we're not gonna go to that guy because I
got a lot of [__] I got to show you
we're gonna do like rabbit around here
um I got a lot of stuff to show you so
let's talk about real quick real quick
the Elon Zuckerberg thing what the [__]
is with that oh the fighter challenge
him yeah what the hell is so
ddlr basically it all started with
somebody yeah okay the long story or the
short story of it is uh uh Zuckerberg
was like yeah let's fight right and
people got to know that Zuckerberg has
been training he's been doing uh uh uh
Jiu Jitsu and now I always paid money to
see that video right dude their actual
videos well they're actual videos of
Mark Zuckerberg training and actually in
a competition right now but
uh Elon Musk said he's down for it he
also said his move will be the walrus
and that move is when you just yeah he
said when you just lay on some but not
saying that you know I don't know maybe
his size but he says that uh he'll do
the walrus which is when you just lay on
someone and don't do anything no wait
why would you want to fight someone and
tell them what you're going to do that
that that's probably a really dumb idea
I don't know but it's not it's right
he's getting Elon Musk trying to be but
what I find funny about this is because
years ago maybe 2018 something like that
I forget the year right Elon Musk there
was an interview that was done with him
and he was talking about his time
growing up in in South Africa right in
apartheid and he was like oh man the
streets of South Africa were dangerous
no doubt about that definitely dangerous
however he said he got into some very uh
I'm trying to remember the phrasing but
basically like hard street fights to
which I'm like hey that [__] never
happened listen he said he got beat up
he said he got beat up which I'm like
yeah I believe that but then he was like
oh we got into the hardcore or her
street brawls and like there's no
there's no reality where Elon and
hardcore ever live in the same sentence
now listen here's what I'll tell you
about this story I I think Elon could
raise all the money to pay off his debt
for Twitter if he sold tickets to him
and Mark Zuckerberg pounding each other
in the face I'm just gonna say that okay
so let's let's move on here to another
person who may or may not want to get in
the ring with someone apparently uh
Margie Taylor green called Lauren bobert
a little [__]
um the other day on the floor is that
the story but here is here is a story
here's a clip of this uh [__]
um on another little bitch's podcast
Matt getz's Firebrand talking about yeah
fire crotch is that the really name
because I love how this is like like
Donald Trump Jr's like I'm triggered so
I'll call my I'll call my show triggered
it'd be great it'd be great Mac dates
he's like I'm a fire brain yeah
oh my God yeah yeah man I even got a
license plate from the state of New
Hampshire that says fire brand what a
dumb [__] dividing Administration here
is here is here's Marjorie Taylor green
on uh fire pantses
um uh podcast then the Pentagon uh
everybody running the military they
ignore the American Border I think our
military should be stacked at the
southern border and the northern border
I think we should be defending our
country I think we should be fighting
the cartels and not not the Russians oh
oh any opportunity for her to talk about
how we shouldn't be fighting her God
Putin isn't that funny did she say she
wants to though yes yes the north Canada
right that's what she's saying she's
afraid that socialism is gonna seep
through the goddamn invisible borders
with with the mountie
they're like hey and it's like
that's how that's how you get in that's
how you get into socialism right that's
what she's really afraid of she's afraid
of not this Russian oligarch and
genocide War King
she's afraid of the socialism
on [__] horses coming through scary
speaking of socialist I want to tell you
something a lot of people have been
yelling and screaming about Joe Biden
not debating someone right yeah right
okay you're here okay well let me let
them at least why should he not have a
legitimate debate well and that being
like don't go on a [__] Twitter space
to announce your candidacy for president
or go on to a Twitter space begging
to be uh taken seriously right right now
the other debate is Joe Biden they don't
want Joe Budden Joe Biden not debating
he's the incumbent prison okay this is
how it works this how it works for
[__] years it's never not worked this
way the incumbent president never
debates anyone one of the reasons why is
because the the incumbent president has
already debated people in their party
now I want to show you a clip of someone
this is [__] masterful now a lot of
people think I hate Bernie Sanders I
don't hate Bernie Sanders I like Bernie
Sanders I like Bernie Sanders as the
independent senator from Vermont that
can say whatever the [__] he wants
whenever he wants however he wants now
I'm going to show you this clip and then
we'll talk about debating Joe Biden
after this is it really free if you're
raising taxes to pay for it well given
the fact that we have the billionaire
class paying a lower tax rate than
Working Families I think it's
appropriate the wealthiest people in
this country start paying their fair
share of taxes thanks very much Wall
Street tax would hit average American
saving for retirement what people say
that people on Wall Street thank you
totally I mean just watch this fox or
news reporter
right dunks are straight in the dresses
here's the best part about this whole
thing folks if you're wondering why Joe
Biden shouldn't have to debate and there
I'll give you one good [__] reason
I'll give you one good [__] reason he
had to debate this guy okay he had to
debate Bernie Sanders several times
several times Bernie Sanders brought the
smoke to Joe Biden and Joe Biden won
that primary okay if you're still
standing around wondering why Joe Biden
didn't have to debate is because he
debated one of one of the best Debaters
in the Democratic caucus in the United
States Senate okay this guy is no slouch
Bernie Sanders knows his [__] he's known
as [__] he doesn't change his position
this guy's a [__] chairman okay he's
not even he's not even a Democrat he's
an independent as you see here on the
the Chiron he's an independent and he's
a chairman for the Democratic caucus no
slouch now the reason why Joe Biden
doesn't have to debate is because he
debated Bernie Sanders several times and
he beat him that is why that's why he
already did the debate thing already did
it doesn't have to do it now I want the
Bernie Sanders people to come tell me
why it's not significant that Joe Biden
debated Bernie Sanders several times and
beat him again Bernie Sanders is one of
the most formidable opponents in
debating we we remember 2016 when he
would destroy Hillary Clinton on stage
he did a masterful job when he was
debating Joe Biden most of the time but
Joe Biden still beat him so I want you
to tell me why the bar of debating
Bernie Sanders isn't a big enough bar I
want you to come tell me why that is now
foggy Ozarks here he meant [__] you
hey [__] you all right oh my God
um it also it also goes to show you that
like you know you have these Fox
reporters trying to get a sound bite in
or whatever and it's like yeah you got
your sound bite you got [__] slapped
down but the idea that they're like oh
we're gonna come in and we're gonna
we're gonna expose you know democrats
for you know or or Independence for for
trying to uh come after the rich guy
right because that's that's what Fox
News is trying to say right they don't
like the fact that rich people are get
have to pay their fair share
for uh for their wages right and the
idea that they're ignoring a huge huge
income gap inequality right huge gap and
they don't want to accept it because
that would go against you know it it's
it's always funny to watch how
Republicans will you know obviously uh
go against their own constituents and
their own constituents will vote against
their own best interests right and it's
this constant cycle of of feeding
through distance and misinformation of
saying like you don't need more money
and them complaining about well I don't
have enough money and then Republicans
and Fox News continue to spread well
it's not our fault it's the Democrats
right and you see it go again oh yeah
it's always it's always well you know we
got a lot of people here on the
broadcast and I want to remind everyone
why you're on the broadcast make sure to
subscribe to the YouTube channel while
you're here on the broadcast if you're
on YouTube click subscribe it's free
it's also free to follow us on Twitch so
don't forget to do that and if you want
to watch from Facebook if you still have
a Facebook account depending on who you
want to win Elon or Zuckerberg but if
you're on team Zuckerberg and you still
have a Facebook account go go to Anthony
Tony Michaels watch us on Facebook as
well now back to your point yeah of
these people these the [__] sandwich
eating this [__] sandwich right yeah
yeah uh yesterday we want some clips uh
[__] [__] look at this sorry look at
this guy look at this guy so we we
watched yesterday a few clips of John
Durham getting his ass handed to him one
of them from Adam's ship which I want to
come back to that yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah again it's a waterfall news
um or a lot of news at the bottom of the
sea whichever you uh prefer your your
analogy there here is uh here's Matt
gatz that okay if you're wondering if
manga is going to absolutely
[__] toss up Jim Jordan and James
Comer in the trash when they can't
develop any results for Donald Trump
against Hunter Biden or Biden uh just
watch this clip this is this is the
future because remember Durham oh man
there was a big hero Gabe Sanchez and
I'm sure Matt gets we can pull he was
gonna expose it all man that's right
that's right and Hillary is guilty and
Matt gatz probably has many tweets out
there that we could pull up to show you
how Matt gants loved loved the idea of
John Durham weaponizing government
against Hillary Clinton and Joe Biden
and Barack Obama but let's see how Mr
gatz responds to Mr Durham since he
didn't produce the results that he
wanted
I think that's beyond the scope of
what's in the report it's literally the
scope of what your charging order is who
put it in motion we get after it was put
in
bunch of wrong and corrupt things
totally understand we're trying to deal
with that but when you are part of the
cover-up Mr Durham and it makes our job
harder
did he just say did he just say that
Durham is the Deep state is that what he
said I mean it sounds like he's there to
say that the report didn't
fully
satisfy Matt Gates's appetite and that
he's he goes oh well FBI we know they
did wrong but you you my friend did not
deliver and do the thing that you said
you were gonna do not only did you not
deliver because you didn't deliver
because you didn't now you are deep
State you are you are part of the cover
I'm pretty sure I'm gonna go look
through uh Matt Gates's tweets and find
out oh yeah find what he said about
[__] Durham right okay well find out
why we play more because this gets
[__] this gets crazy do you know the
you know the Harlem Globetrotters are
right yeah yeah you know that the
Washington generals are the team that
always plays the Globetrotters right
okay Durham does not know that when when
Matt gatz says this but but listen to
this exchange about the the Washington
General this is I can't tell you how
delicious this is just watch yeah well
if that's your thought I mean there's no
way of dissuading you from that I can
tell you that it's offensive and that
the people who worked on this
investigation Nation have spent their
lives trying to protect people in this
country and pursue within the law what
it is authorized to do you tried two
cases lost both of them and then the One
Plea guilty plea you got Klein Smith
Klein Smith is back to practicing law in
Washington DC today
that's beyond my control right but but
the the fact that you allowed that
please okay I want to point out I don't
know who this congressman is here
sitting next to Matt Getz I don't
recognize him he's some nobody but he is
really he's like this is cringe dude
Matt gants you're totally reading too
much left-wing Twitter because left-wing
Twitter's like this [__] guy is a
loser he's a trump loser he lost two
[__] court cases in The Plea the
guilty plea did get is a bunch of
[__] so much so that the guy who
took the deal is back practicing law in
Washington DC Matt gets I I don't know
how to tell you folks this this is why
narrative matters this is why it [__]
matters Matt gatz he's such an idiot
here he's playing into our narrative
he's doing it right and he's doing it
because he's trying to own the libs to
make Durham the Deep State one of us
he's a lib no no his friend that's not
what you're doing you're only playing
into our narrative is what you're doing
but once let's listen to how he he does
the whole Harlem Globetrotters things
this is this is fantastic
right and and then the punishment was
insufficient the fact that you didn't
you didn't charge Andrew McCabe you
didn't convict the lion Democrat answer
the line yeah you didn't investigate me
or the Mueller probe
a black letter that was your chocolate
listen dude listen I got a clip okay
good listen dude with your comeback hair
he couldn't even get the convictions of
the low-level actors you dumb
[__] why do you think he would
be able to bring charges or anything
against the high-level actors you
[__] idiot Jesus Christ This Guy's
such a [__] well let's keep going with
the idiocy the idiocracy it is
have you ever heard of the Washington
generals here it is at the Washington
generals yes yeah and they're the
show up and lose right Durham has no
idea what he's talking about you know
I'm sure that the players who um
exert Blood Sweat and Tears Don't view
it that way but you might I think they
do I think they do because the job of
the Washington generals is to show up
every night and to play the Harlem
Globetrotters okay so for those of you
who don't know there's a team called the
Harlem Globetrotters and it's more of a
performance than an actual game and the
reason why is because the Washington
generals are the team that always play
the the Harlem Globetrotters because
they're in on it right they're in on it
they're supposed to lose it's a show
it's not really a game it's a show and
Matt gants is trying to say that Durham
is the Washington generals this is what
he's trying to do but Durham doesn't
know who the Washington generals are
until this moment where he says the
Harlem Globetrotters and it starts to
ring in his head I think I don't know
who he's thinking about
um but I think he's thinking like a
baseball team or something because
there's the Washington Nationals right
yeah yeah yeah and I think that's what
Durham's thinking but Durham obviously
you might say that this references to
inside baseball
it's just about a lot of black dudes
playing basketball in Durham doesn't
like that kind of stuff it could be you
know I don't know maybe that's it but
let's listen to how Durham finally comes
around to the Harlem Globetrotters and
the Washington generals let's see how he
comes around to it and their job I'm
thinking I'm sorry a bit different I was
thinking of it yeah yeah so their job is
to lose and I'm kind of wondering and it
just see it just seems so facially
obvious that it's not what's in your
report that's telling it's the Omission
it's the lack of work you did and for
the people like the chairman who put
trust in you I think you let them down I
think you let the country down and you
are one of the barriers to the true
accountability that we need oh my God so
what Matt Getz wants is once John Durham
to lie is what he wants he wants sham
investigations and John Durham didn't
give him the Sham investigations that he
so sought so ridiculous so what is this
clip that you sent me so this clip this
definitely is not posted from Matt
gatz's uh official account surely not
nope
so I've been I've been as as you were
talking to him playing the clip I was
going through a bunch of his tweets so
basically they transitioned
from tweets and commentary like this
which is what I'm about to show yeah
yeah and it transitioned into moments of
where's John Durham what's going on with
John Durham is John like and then he
began to question like the legitimacy uh
support that Matt Gates had for John
Durham to say like
uh it's clear to me that John Durham
like in another tweet he transitioned to
say
I do not believe that Durham trial of
Michael Sussman is about convicting
Sussman at all the entire purpose of
this trial is to inoculate the FBI and
the doj against the charge that they
were in on the Russia hoax okay so that
was 2020 uh 2012.
um so it's transitioning still has this
deep State going on thing going on but
now he's fully made the leap over right
from John Durham is going to prosecute
and show everyone what the FBI and the
doj did to John Durham you didn't do
anything you goddamn cuck right well you
know that's how it ended this is how it
started right now Matt gants tweeting
Durham probably frightens the Deep State
well how is that possible if he is the
Deep State a lot more than even the
Pfizer review which is all the Pfizer
review is all [__] anyways because
all they proved with the Pfizer review
is that they didn't have the information
in the right sequence of time to get the
fisa not that they shouldn't have
received a warrant they just didn't get
it in the sequence that is normal or
should be normal and they've changed
that it says the German he says the
Durham investigation is is the
investigation like that do they do they
think they have to use the word
investigation more than once yes they
use it more than once
then it makes it seem legitimate right
well here's the scary black dude thing
he says the Durham investigation is the
investigation that goes the deepest the
deepest into the Obama White House you
see that oh the scary black man okay see
this is 2019 by the way so 2019 they
were still using the scary black guy
thing
um and he says I think you'll see
Clapper and Brennan implicated do you
even remember who these people are at
this point no I know exactly exactly
um I mean a bunch of Q and honors would
but here's Matt Getz this is a
transition though because we can talk
about shift after this okay yeah well
that's where I wanted to go with this
yeah that's where I wanted to go with
this anyways Donald Trump is innocent
and the Deep state is guilty and and
when you've got Mr Durham out there with
an investigation that transitioned from
an administrative review to a criminal
investigation that is a hat tip that
there was some catalyzing event that
caused the attorney general and Mr
Durham to seek the ability to have of
the criminal process at their disposal I
also think Durham probably frightens the
Deep State a lot more than even the fisa
review because the Durham investigation
is the investigation that goes deepest
into the Obama White House and so that's
why I think you'll see people like
Clapper and Brennan implicated now I I
want to say you need to stop doing drugs
before you go on vaccines you should get
cottonmouth man
you got to tell me
Trump is
dude you really gotta you gotta stop
John Durham is gonna show you the deep
State he's got to quit hitting the ball
before he goes on Fox yeah he's got a
horrible cottonmouth in this interview
now this is all nonsense right it's just
how many times can I put deep State into
my little statement on Fox News
basically no again it's the boogeyman if
you don't if you don't want to talk
about the real problem which is Donald
Trump criminal right then you say oh
well it's a deep state right it's you
know it's the same way that we're going
to hear this [__] in the Twitter spaces
all the time
they talk about the Deep State they said
it was sore Rose like if they ever
Republicans never want to address the
real [__] elephant in the room which
is their party and their projection of
their own crimes then they look to
someone else say I was planted it was a
hoax it was a setup it was a Witch Hunt
it's a this it's that it's fake news
right you saw what the documents you see
what Jan six you see with all of these
things every time something comes up
they try to oh whoa whoa isn't it isn't
it oh my life's gone isn't it super
convenient that Donald Trump's
indictment happened right when these
tapes were going to be released and it's
like well if you've got to take what
tapes yeah release them let's see let's
see him uh I I wanna I wanna show you
something that they did they did dirt uh
Lindsey Graham dirty on this Chiron you
see this here it says coming behind
coming behind Matt gatz Senator Lindsey
Graham I'm just saying they shouldn't
out Lindsey Graham
um on the Chiron there yeah
it was a little it was a little you know
uh
as Rob says the Derp State got to Gabe's
light and they did I talked too much
about the Derp state
but yeah it's you know okay because
that's what they do speaking speaking of
Adam Schiff did you hear Yesterday
um I couldn't because he was [__]
censured yeah that's true did you see
that they didn't what the huge favor
that they didn't listen the only per and
I said this in the first half hour the
only person yesterday that was really
disappointed with this was was Katie
Porter she's like wow [__] I totally
wanted to run for United States Senate
to California and now this [__]
now he's elevated to like the Enemy
Number One which is only gonna give him
a huge platform in California to raise
money and run on I I believe the problem
that they're gonna have is they've now
basically made uh Adam Schiff the front
runner in the senate race uh for the the
senate seat that Feinstein will be
leaving
um and and in that way it's crazy but
this is this is nuts all right you
remember this Rogaine guy I keep trying
to go back to this [__] okay
this is his this is his [__] response
yeah to to yesterday right this is his
take on it which he's been clamoring for
weeks he was attacking Thomas man Massey
as derp State he's like Thomas Madison
part of the deep State yeah right we
don't want him look we're the Deep State
man we don't want that [__] you
can eat Thomas Massey okay keep Thomas
Massey keep John Durham you can have him
deep State doesn't want him but here's
what DC Drano says about he says this
historic censure is what happens when we
the people push our reps to fight the
Deep State he [__] put the words in
there oh my God he goes on to clamor up
on they tried to stop us who the [__] is
us last week but we made our voices loud
and clear you were trying oh oh this is
probably last year or last week is the
arraignment right well not only do you
well okay but but they also tried to do
this with a shift before and it failed
right right yeah because they were
trying to find find him six million
dollars and there were Republican
members of Congress like whoa wait a
second you mean you want to set the
president to to to find members of
Congress for 16 million dollars for
doing their job I don't think that's a
good idea there was enough of them to
say [__] that [__] he goes on to say the
days of business as usual are over oh oh
oh just now just now you people are not
gonna be normal are you [__] kidding
me you people have been normal for eight
[__] years and eight [__] years
you people haven't even seen seen a
glimpse of normal get the [__] out of
here it goes on to say this is this is
incredible I can't even tell you how
[__] dumb this is he says we took
down Bud Light oh my God we took down
Target go check their stocks Rogaine and
he says now we've centered Adam's ship
know what you've done you [__] fool
what you've done is you've made Adam
Schiff the front runner to be a United
States Senator but also censuring and I
guess we have to go back to where this
all started right can you can you
explain to everyone
why representative Luna put forward this
resolution to censure Adam ship like
what did he say and when did he say it
because he was effective
I mean he's effective yeah but
specifically how old were the comments
at the Deep State meeting that we have
yeah Adam Schiff is one of the most
effective people and we hire him and we
hold them in high regard when we pass
out the antifa cookies right right we
all have our antifa deep State
membership card we keep it in our
[__] fanny packs by the way this is
where you're supposed to keep your
antifa and your deep State card okay
it's in a [__] fanny pack you can get
them at store.d Tony michaels.com it's
the official storage place for your
antifa membership card or your deep
State membership card but I said the
Deep State really Revere Adam Schiff as
our leader he's the cult leader he's the
one that gives all the direction uh
Daniel Goldman pointed out great on the
floor of the houses this was happening
he's like look [__] ship is is not
only the director of the FBI he's the
leader of the deep State the guy the guy
the guy is a sitting United States
Congressman but he also controls the
fisa courts he control those courts he
controls all sorts of stuff and ship is
really the central the central Hub of
all power when it comes to the antifa
Deep State now you want to know they
tried to do this last week as well and
they failed well then that's in their
wheelhouse yeah right and then Donald
Trump came out and said if you don't
support this
then I won't support you right is
because he's he basically threatened to
say like if you don't if you don't vote
like anyone who voted no on this
resolution this this uh last week if you
or how many ever days after if you don't
vote Yes on the like going forward I'm
going to make sure to have someone
primary you right isn't that what
happened he threatened their position
he's always threatening them and and I
mean I can tell you this threatening to
primary someone
as a representative or Senator like you
take that very seriously the ability
that you know uh you could lose your
position by just having a nobody who
could still potentially lose right
um but when we think back right like
Adam schiff's role in you know Trump
impeachment proceeding but the idea that
he didn't really say it he didn't really
do anything new right like this is
they're trying to Drudge up old stuff
right and present this on like there
wasn't anything that prompted them or
instigated them there wasn't any emo
like how because yesterday it's an ax to
grind now here's the thing here's the
thing it is funny timing though wow
after yesterday I mean it was like oh
boy this after yesterday's
events of Adam Schiff [__] dragging
John Durham
to prove that the that Russians did act
Russia did actually help Donald Trump
and uh don Jr trying to get
um
dirt on Hillary Clinton is in this
wheelhouse of of you know being illegal
and to prove that the Durham report
actually was a nothing Burger
they all did that but Adam Schiff was
one who like kept hitting him back and
back and back and
my belief and I'm pretty sure this is
probably fairly accurate is
that it was that experience that
prompted
Luna to put forward this this vote to
censure Adam Schiff but again we have to
remember
that they tried this last week and the
reason for them is that they're they're
pulling all of this stuff back up from
years ago when he went after Trump
originally so like they they really hold
on to grudges and they're very Petty
when it comes to something that is
uh is going to be a huge rake in the
face okay so um speaking of rakes I'm
going to come back to this but uh there
I do have a video a a clip of the U.S
Coast Guard update of the uh these uh
the Ocean Gate
um submersible but Brenda says here they
sent your uh uh him to please Trump I'll
I'll go one step further they censored
him because they need to please the cult
they [__] [__] the bed on the The Joe
Biden the Joe Biden Hunter Biden's now
going to take a plea deal that [__]
totally destroys their narrative that he
wasn't investigated for all these crimes
they can't stop stepping on rakes so
they're trying to find a rake that they
can step on that isn't going to backfire
on them and I believe that centering
Adam Schiff is one of the biggest freaks
they step on I'll point out why but here
here um we're gonna go here this is a
Sky News uh clip I think Ron had it here
um we're gonna play this this see what
the update is apparently to debris that
they have found on the the floor I guess
the floor of the ocean is part of uh
this this submersible craft which means
um they're they're it's the tin can
crumble but let's let's listen
our president is uh
uh directly connected to the the ships
that are out there and the message that
they're telling me if you're talking
about debris
it was a landing frame and a rear cover
from the submersible
so again this is a very unconventional
submarine the
that rear cover is that point the end of
it yeah
and I I just want to point out because
I'm not a scientist and I don't know
nothing about submarines
um
I I love how he calls it an
unconventional right because it is right
right but that's that's a hell of a way
to [__] dress it up I'm just gonna
say but here's the thing here's the
thing
if the rear cover came off that thing
there ain't no bodies to be found there
is no way in that depth of a ocean that
a human body would survive I just sent
you a clip and
um so yesterday you know I talked about
the effects that different pressure
levels have right right and we showed
that we showed that we showed the uh the
infograph right right the graphic like
one of them was like you know near the
bottom but about Midway through is like
if you were to pop a bottle of champagne
the cork would go inside it would that's
so much pressure it would it would fold
in on itself okay that gives you an idea
right everyone knows [__] popping a
bottle of champagne can be dangerous
especially where you direct it but this
is going in on itself so this video that
I just sent you gives you an idea of
exactly or not exactly but a rough idea
of kind of what what happened okay so
let's finish the the news report and
then I'll go to that video The Landing
frame is this
little frame that it seems to sit on and
that's how it gets stopped into the
landing bit right so that confirms it's
the submersible
oh boy so so it seems that they're
confirming that yes they did find debris
which is not good for the people well
what were the people inside there's
probably not much of them left and this
is um this is the video that you're
saying kind of gives an idea of why that
would be and how that would work
um here's this video here let's take a
listen
oh it's not a listener whoa Jesus [__]
Christ yeah oh God damn so so what what
there's another one as well uh here's
the here's another example
oh Jesus Christ so this is this is uh
this is a a small fraction
of the pressure that they would have
been at at the depth that they were down
there right so if there's if so wait
this isn't even the actual uh this is
not a one-to-one ratio because I guess
you probably can't you probably can't um
on the surface you can't probably
emulate that right well yeah I mean you
can emulate it to an extent but again
this is okay this is a just a mere
fraction of what the pressure was down
at the bottom of the ocean right
wherever they were again they were you
know an hour and 45 minutes they were
they were they were out before
everything cut off right and the
question was did they lose communication
or did a catastrophic event happen and
it is assumed as of yesterday that most
likely what happened was a catastrophic
event and again this is just showing you
uh it's it said it well let me read here
it says train Tank Vacuum implosion at
one atmospheric pressure okay that's
just one this is what happens at one
yeah the Titan or the Ocean Gate craft
or the submersible or submarine whatever
the hell you want to call it is around
375 right
in the thread because some people think
oh that's not actually what it is so
Adam Stewart the guy who posted this
said One ATM the pressure above your
head standing on Earth is approximately
14.7 pounds per square inch okay right
now this is the pressure that that when
you're when you're on the surface of
these on the surface like right now
there's just 14.7 but because there's
pressure there's pressure all around you
ready
14.7 pounds per square inch the immense
pressure at 2.5 miles of an ocean depth
is immediately appreciated by what you
would see right you you've now
exponentially increase the amount of
pressure that you would have now again
if 14.7 pounds is one
who do the math as to what having
something that's 2.5 miles down or 375
ATM
it's instant right there was no it was
done right it [__] something as soon
as there was a pinhole or whatever the
pressure whatever it might have been the
the differential in pressure between the
the tin can and the the ocean water
that's
what it does to the actual craft yeah um
let alone but I can tell you that like
in this example right here that we just
showed
I can it would probably if I had to
guess it would probably look like
something like when you take a like
aluminum foil right and you Crump it up
into a ball
like it's tight it is tight at that
point because again this is on Earth and
there's and it's it's a simulated amount
of pressure and it's a fraction of what
was down in the ocean now
this is why you would probably if you
paid 250 000 to get into a little uh
submarine like this you'd probably want
to make sure someone tested it and
certified it and made sure that it could
I don't know make the journey number one
number two be safe on the journey and
and number three
um had failed as Fail-Safe systems in
place to make sure that you could get
back to the surface because if you
didn't you would reach your ultimate
demise similar to the way that we just
shown in this video Yeah holy [__] so it
appears it appears the news is that
um that they're going to be scraping
what is left of this craft on now now
the question comes into like I know that
they signed this agreement that said
Ocean Gate is not responsible at all
blah blah blah all this [__] right
but there's a part of me that could see
family members come after right this I
mean because when they sign this the
assumption
despite you know whatever crazy desire
that these people had to go down to the
bottom of the ocean thinking that 250k
would would actually save them right and
actually and actually somebody just
brought up a good point that I saw which
is
it's 250 000 plus millions in taxpayers
yeah because and that's not enough [__]
yeah we're spending a shitload of money
to find it let's scrape it off the
bottom of the ocean pull it up
investigate it figure out what the hell
happened that's not only the US that's
also other countries like I think Canada
Canada
wasn't the um I think it was this
morning I read or late last night they
had an actual because they had like
something that could retrieve it if they
actually found it yeah what I mean by
that is if they still found it and it
was and it was intact they were trying
to figure out how the hell they're gonna
[__] tether to it and bring it back
to the surface right yeah website a
piece of equipment uh the Canadian Navy
finally got a piece of equipment that
they believed that if they did find it
intact just last night like they just
came to where this is at just last night
with this piece of equipment that they
believed that they could get down and
actually tether to it and pull it up if
it was intact which it doesn't the news
seems to be that it's not intact just
like Kevin McCarthy's reputations sorry
I'm going to move on yeah Kevin
McCarthy's reputation is just as smashed
up as this submersible after yesterday
when he
attempted uh successfully well or
unsuccessfully whichever to capitulate
to Maga um this guy man really he looks
[__] defeated when he's announcing
this this is because Democrats are
yelling shame in him they're yelling him
they're heckling him you know what uh oh
my God Kevin McCarthy reminds me of in
this moment right here
um he reminds me of a substitute teacher
yeah right who the kids the kids are
like I'm not gonna listen to anything
you have to say
I'm gonna do whatever I want and they
just [__] yell and or it could be a
teacher who's like a new teacher right
and the kids have identified the [__]
weakness right and they go straight for
the [__] jugular and meanwhile Kevin
McCarthy's up there like a [__]
teacher that just he's like oh he didn't
know what the hell I did not all of my
schooling in in in in and uh in practice
in preparation did not get me ready
for this [__] right here and so he looks
like he's just done oh he looks like he
did he's defeat well he has to do this
he doesn't have a choice they're forcing
him to do this um because I don't think
he really wants to but they don't have
anything else to do I mean this is the
moment when I think Kevin McCarthy is
regretting ever winning speaker right
well you know they they've already
they've already got rid of the 85 000
IRS agents that didn't actually exist
they save gas stoves from nothing right
they totally proved that any evidence
that that
um they could make up is not evidence
against Joe Biden and Hunter Biden so
why not why not go on this um this
Escapade of censuring and making uh Adam
Schiff the front runner for the United
States is the United States Senate race
in California but let's listen uh to how
Kevin McCarthy felt after the vote
resolution 521
the house has resolved
that the house of
uh
they're just hacking them can you pull
up the clip of Adam Schiff uh his speech
it's like six minutes I want to play it
if we got a few minutes but let's listen
to more on how defeated Kevin McCarthy
is here
I have all night
resolution 521 the house is resolved
[Applause]
that the House of Representatives
censures Adam Schiff representative of
the 30th congressional district of
California
oh great doing the people's work there
Kev God damn you're really helping the
American people with inflation and all
that [__] that you guys promised oh man
why don't you just move on to to [__]
destroying Social Security and Medicare
for for all the average working
Americans why don't you do that why
don't you just destroy the American
Safety net for all these that's that's
what is that is that next on the list I
mean what else do they have right I mean
they don't really have anything else I
mean like the idea that they are really
stuck to
doing the thing that they said they
wouldn't do even though they wanted to
do it in the first place which is cut
all these programs you know and they're
like no no guys we're focusing on the
real good the real important stuff like
censoring Adam Schiff now did he do
anything per se no no he didn't well I
mean he held he yelled uh treasonous
piece of [__] accountable yeah and he
and he made forbid we asked the
questions the party that loves to ask
questions you know inquisitive Minds
right wants to know the answer so that
that we don't get away with this corrupt
nature of this deep State and this swamp
but as soon as you bring up an example
and say hey who's the swamp you exposed
look at this Swamp Thing right this
[__] swamp creature they go
he's easy On The Backs like I always
tell you easy on the facts easy on the
facts and that's really what Adam Schiff
is guilty of but here's here's a here's
a snippet I think it was like a six
minute speech Adam shift game and I'll
tell you what it's this is one of the
best [__] speeches I've ever seen on
the floor because Adam Schiff did not go
to the floor and say [__] you you some
[__] I can't believe you did this he
was like thank you very much thank you
thank you so much for making me your
enemy you treasonous pieces of [__]
idiots here's here's a break here's a
rake for you here's a rake for you
everyone gets a rake right here's a rake
you get a rake you get a rake step on
those [__] and they sure did
but let's watch Adam Schiff point out
how they like to rake step someone's
recognized
to my Republican colleagues who
introduced this resolution I thank you
you honor me with your end machine you
flatter me with this falsehood you who
are the authors of a big lie about the
last election must condemn the truth
tellers and I stand proudly before you
your words tell me that I have been
effective in the defense of our
democracy and I am grateful
and yet this false and defamatory
resolution comes at a considerable cost
to the country and to the Congress okay
I just want to point out the reason why
they censored Adam Schiff is because
he's so good at this right
right you try to silence right those who
challenge you and are effective at doing
so and they still have to like oh well
he was involved with the impeachment one
he's clearly going to be exposing these
things and then yesterday when he takes
that dermaport and [__] shits on it
and then smears it all over the
Republican party they got very upset and
then Luna was like I want to bring up
this thing that I tried to pass last
week but it failed
well good luck to him let's let's listen
in a little more on Adam and Schiff
at a moment when millions of people in
our home state of California are unable
to find a place to live or afford a
place to live speaker McCarthy chooses
to occupy the resources of Congress for
two straight weeks on this hollow sop to
the Maga crowd he offers nothing to
those who are homeless or addicted to
opioids or to millions of college
students mired in debt but this paltry
distraction
Donald Trump is under indictment for
actions that jeopardize our national
security and McCarthy would spend the
nation's time on Petty political payback
thinking he can censure or find Trump's
opposition into submission but I will
not yield not one inch
the cost to the speaker's delinquency is
high but the cost to Congress of this
frivolous and yet dangerous resolution
may be even higher as it represents
another serious abuse of power Donald
Trump has threatened that any of you
that defy him and vote against this
partisan resolution will be met by a
primary Challenge and he calls for my
imprisonment
if a transient majority can punish an
attempt to silence members who hold a
corrupt president to account there is no
telling what further Corruption of
office will follow
and I say this to speaker McCarthy and
others who wish to gratify Donald Trump
with this act of subservience or been to
his demands try as you might to expel me
from Congress or silence me with a 16
million dollar fine you will not succeed
you might as well make it 160 million
you will never deter me from doing my
duty oh my God just watch those
[__] up and throws them in the
garbage oh man Adam Schiff man I tell
you what if you're not if you're not
aware this speech is is exactly what
Adam Schiff needed to become the front
runner in the United States Senate race
um in California and again I I know
Katie Porter uh I I I think Adam
Schiffer Katie Porter would be great
great United States senators they're
both very good at this uh but Adam
Schiff uh last night proved that he can
stand in the face of these treasonous
bastards and and show them what
democracy can really do and I think he
will be the front runner uh in the
senate race and and I I I I was hoping
for Katie Porter to be quite honest I
think there should be more women that
are elevated to power but
um in in the light of what happened
yesterday when not only did they censure
him on the floor uh as a direct uh um
order from Donald Trump because he is
Donald Trump's number one enemy it is
clear why it is clear why because all
the indictments that are going to come
all the information that is going to be
a waterfall on Donald Trump when there's
January six indictments come when the
Georgia indictments come Adam Schiff
will be there Adam Schiff will be will
be powerful he he will be right in their
face and they're terrified of it they're
[__] terrified of the truth that's
that's that's yeah it's just funny it's
just funny because Adam Schiff is my rep
and my where I live in in California so
you get to vote for him yeah so I get to
vote for him uh but also because
yesterday you know I was I didn't get
the text message because I don't I don't
think I signed up for them right uh you
just go vote for them you don't need
yeah I just go vote for him but I you
know friend was over yesterday and they
got a text message and and she was like
holy [__] and I was like what's wrong
and she goes oh nothing it's just like a
a donation uh uh like text message and I
was like oh is it from Adam Schiff and
she goes no it's not from Adam Schiff
and I was like what do you mean it's got
to be like who else would be fundraising
right now and then she looks and she's
like oh wait no it actually it's from
ownership and it basically was like oh
I've been censured and data this and
that and I need your support you know
right right and I yeah again I I really
I I don't I don't believe that whether
it's uh Katie Porter or Adam Schiff and
I know there's a few others in the race
but those are the two people that will
probably likely um take that primary
um either one of them uh I'm fine with
but yesterday I'm I'm pretty yeah
Katie Porter's chances here have really
um been diminished because now Adam
Schiff is Trump's number one enemy and
this election rather you like or not is
going to be about Donald Trump and his
crime speaking of his crimes
and tight shirts holy [__] this guy just
keeps popping up or popping out of his
little sister's shirt everywhere listen
to this oh my God
would you take not just legal advice
would you take any advice from this guy
listen then you can tell me if he could
open his eyes information over the last
few weeks what does he do that Biden
coerced
a bribe from barisma we got new
information over the last few weeks from
showing banking records uh detailing
banking records that show Money flowing
in from China to the Biden family in a
way that was obviously money laundering
and what happens Trump gets arrested
what happens don't what happens Tony
Trump gets arrested again it's this
projection this idea that looks like
Tony you don't understand okay I have
the it totally looks like it totally
looks it totally looks like a blank
piece of paper it's 100 blankets is
there anything on that thing no not a
goddamn thing he's like look look Biden
clearly why is he swiveling in the chair
because he has nothing of Merit he
doesn't know what he's talking about
he's trying to talk out of his ass and
remember this is the guy who told Trump
despite his lawyers especially kais the
lawyer who was paid three million
dollars on actual lawyer the actual
[__] lawyer someone who was invested
financially uh into his client
this is the guy right here Tom Finn the
the small shirt steroid raging
fake lawyer who told Donald Trump not to
give in and and give the documents back
Donald Trump could have avoided this
whole [__] thing if he just would
have listened to kais and said oh my bad
here are the documents here are the
boxes here's all the stuff and then
you have Tom Finn here who says don't do
it don't do it fight them fight the doj
you [__] them you had the right to have
him Melody uh the uh asked a question
here on Facebook she says I watched him
who is he this is this is the guy that
Donald Trump is taking his legal advice
for this guy is not a lawyer this is the
guy you emailed the White House on
Halloween 2020 and told them or the
election yeah and you can you can it's
it it's a you can look up Tom fit and
letter
uh 10 31 2020 it was it was used and
shown and the Jan six hearing you can
see the full document basically it says
there before the election happened
remember this is like a week before the
election it said there was an election
and we won
and it was him telling Donald Trump the
White House that they should just
preemptively uh say oh you know what
there's a bunch of fraud out there we
can't take it seriously Donald Trump won
without even knowing the results of the
election okay because again this is a
week before there was actually the
election happening in person
was like just tell them that you won Wes
Webb says he needs to get his teeth
fixed he does he has met teeth it looks
like he's hiring [__] in this video I
think that's why he's twisting and
turning and he's I'm telling you man
this is what you do like a little kid
who's like
I mean he looks stoned to the Bone
doesn't he then he looks stoned as [__]
I shared this video and people were like
can he open his eyes and I'm like that's
a good question I don't know I have no
idea what a DJ Fox uh makes a good point
about Tom and his expertise I pick
things up and I put things down
I see me blank piece paper I have a
stool I got a green screen behind me you
must listen to me and the graphic says
Judicial Watch so I gotta know a lot of
stuff about those I know officials
suggestions yeah the judicials are his
expertise
um definitely not even it's not even a
green screen I think it's a big monitor
that's behind him
oh my God
laughs
again there's a thousand comments in the
chat like this again again oh my god oh
[__] this guy oh man look at him he just
like he's like so you know uh right
these documents right and guess what
guess what Gabe Sanchez Donald Trump got
arrested
guess what guess what guess what
everyone Donald Trump got and that's
like the truest thing that he said I
mean it's the only thing that he said
that was the truth
no Donald Trump I'm looking over here at
snack time I gotta take some snacks for
my roids but it's it's uh foreign
my ass got arrested so many of the deep
State swamp creatures that come from
Donald Trump's own Administration that
he even had to admit to during that
interview with Brett Bayer where he was
asked hey you said you only work with
the best people and it turns out you
said all this shitty stuff about these
people Jesus Christ uh sleepy testicles
you guys got them good this guy Tom Finn
is nothing more than a cosplaying lawyer
who he wishes he was a lawyer for sure
no I know I know he's I think if I
remember correctly he's an English major
like that's that's what he like like
training in schooling and education he's
an English major so
he can't even like taking pre-law
programs wait wait so he's so he's an
English major and he couldn't find a
piece of paper that was printed on for
[__] grand out loud at least at least
get your bill that you have for your
gear man because you know this guy's got
a huge and it's not your bill it's not
even like a Masters or anything like
that it's a he went to George Washington
University the George Washington and he
got a ba
in BS
he he got a VA in um in English oh okay
in English that's that's all it is uh
poor guy he got a Bachelor's degree in
English from the University and his
father was a manager his mother was a
nurse okay here's what I hope I hope
Donald Trump keeps getting legal advice
from him that's what I hope because then
Donald Trump will still be getting
arrested like he'll continue to get
arrested I want to point out a a few
comments here uh from earlier speaking
of nicknames and Greg Miller when I when
I did uh Papa felony I don't know Greg
you're onto something he says Papa Mick
felony has a better ring to it so um
maybe we should put that up on a poll on
the podcast again what what nickname is
better Papa felony or Papa Mick felony
which I think the mcveany because you
know he likes McDonald's yeah that's a
he's a big boy Big Mac boy I just want
to point that out soon I appreciate you
guys joining us I'm so glad we had uh
major Ojeda on today we definitely got
to have him back because I I definitely
want the master class on how you
declassify documents with your mind how
the government makes you they train you
how to do that they got to train you how
to do that right it's got to be like a
thing that you got to learn probably
maybe I think I feel like it's it's you
know like E1 e2e oh okay you know
somewhere in their range yeah yeah right
so you're saying waltin probably knows
how to declassify yeah yeah yeah and he
that's why he had him there and he's
like hey go move those things and while
you're at it declassify those bastards
with your mind people need to remember
that if you don't already know
uh waltin our boy waltene cracker uh hid
hid himself in a secret uh passageway
so when Donald Trump would hit the red
button for the diet coke he would go get
a Diet Coke from a mini fridge and then
come down this like secret hallway and
then come out the secret door and then
deliver the diet coke on the desk this
guy
that is that was that was what he's
known for speaking of waltine I've got I
got breaking news here about Walt Teen
um he's moved some more boxes apparently
he's moved them to Donald Trump's
Hollywood star
um they're out where you're from waltina
uh move these boxes I don't know if this
is from yesterday or if it's still out
yeah right but this is um this is
apparently a live look at walteen's
storage of Donald Trump's boxes there at
his Hollywood star uh so
oh you're the best goddamn audience in
the world and because you're the best
audience well guess what I'm giving away
something for free I'm gonna give it
away for free all you gotta do is hit
the Subscribe button it's free it's free
to subscribe it's a free gift to you
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
I want to thank all the people who are
here to see major today go ahead and
subscribe all the sparklers are here
today we had a huge audience today
record-breaking stuff as we had major
object on so thank you very much for
joining us also follow us on Twitter
because you're not going to want to
forget to vote for bonehead of the week
that's right if you're new to the show
we do bonehead of the week tomorrow in
the second hour here's how it works
we put out a poll on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod and on the on the YouTube
account on the community tab you vote
you decide who is the bone end of the
week and then the second hour on Friday
and that's tomorrow me and Gabe Sanchez
break down your vote for the bonehead of
the week so don't miss it make sure to
subscribe on the YouTube channel again
and follow us on Twitter to take that
poll also you can watch tomorrow the
bonehead a week on Facebook at the Tony
Michaels follow us on Facebook at the
Tony Michaels you can also watch it on
the up bars YouTube channel just go to
the upwire.com or type in the up wire in
your YouTube search bar it'll bring it
up there and then follow us on Twitch
it's free to follow us twitch.tv Tony
Michaels and if you would if you got
your Prime account linked to your Twitch
account go ahead and re-subscribe if you
haven't already that would help us out
and if you want to link your your Prime
account to your Twitch account it gives
us a couple bucks each month by giving
us that one free subscription you get
with Amazon gaming we with your Amazon
Prime account when you linked it to if
you need directions here's how you do it
you just go to the Tony michaels.com
that's the Tony michaels.com it's like
the fourth one down it says link Amazon
to Twitch our great moderator Mighty
librarian gave us the directions she put
it online it's right there I link to it
super easy to do if you want to give the
show monetary support speaking of
monetary support if you want a place to
put your deep State antifa membership
card again don't forget to go to
store.thetonymichaels.com and grab your
[__] Pride fanny packs stick that
[__] in there keep it safe with you all
the time when someone especially Matt
gatz is like hey are you the Deep State
you goddamn right I am here's my
membership card [__] so go to store
1920michaels.com check out all the merch
there even all the rake stepping merch
we got that let them eat rake go go
check it out over there we appreciate
all your support as always you're the
best audience in the world and I got it
I got a brand I got a brand new what was
that episode that dropped this morning
so if you wanna want to get early access
to that and some behind the scenes
footage go to what was that show.com or
you can go to patreon.com I am Gabe
Sanchez uh check it out there check it
out there
go ahead go ahead go ahead no I was
gonna say there's uh I got more coming I
got another one I got the Margie Taylor
green Lauren bober coming no George
Santos coming
in are you being a little [__] with the
Marjorie Taylor Greenland I mean I'm not
saying I'm copying all right being a
little [__] you little [__] how do you
think she said like little [__] you
[__] little [__] I think she was
like I can't hear you little [__] she's
like you [__] little [__] you little
[__]
[__] and then she and then and then she
did some [__] hang cleans right right
right that's probably what she was doing
that's batch you hit a [__]
oh my God oh my God that's so hilarious
that's great I can't wait to see the
Elon uh Zuck cage match and I definitely
can't wait to see the Lauren bobert
marger Taylor green cage match you
remember the celebrity boxing
remember that celebrity death match
that's it that's it that's what we
should do
in this corner I can't do the let's get
ready to run because it's all it's well
separated let's get ready to Fumble I
don't know you know you could do
something ladies and gentlemen
oh let's get it ready to Fumble
oh you think we'll get sued for that no
I think if we can find something else
like some people like Trumbull like
Trumbull tumble something like maybe
stumble oh there you go stumble ready to
stumble I think that's I think that's it
yeah Ryan thanks let's get ready to
surround Bowl everybody same time same
place tomorrow don't [__] miss it
you're gonna want to be here bonehead of
the week we got a plenty of these
[__] idiots to pick from so go vote
on the YouTube channel and on Twitter
vote both because we want this pole
rigged bone of the week tomorrow Friday
same time same place
surf set [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mewborn headass Beacon
every disease with the last name
is ridiculous
[Music]
let's be clear
no no
okay now I get to talk